yeah hello really busy day today so bit
of a late video but I wanted to get at
least a small one out today some small
one but that is wrong it's free and -
right well let's get going
a shorter video small one sounds odd
see
if almost all the work is done for today
but have a later live show The Late Show
in English
Sam don't get an opponent him
Oh
you
all right it takes a long time maybe if
I do it without the rating
yeah slightly slightly lower rating than
the 2200 that I usually have as a filter
playing Heisenberg Pinkman okay
sticking with my usual
move warrior to get her Catalan and he
plays the closed catalan
often times not the most
we are comfortable variation
is helpful gives me this full tempo now
yeah that is actually interesting
because Bishop d6 and ninety-six look
good and I think I'm going 96 bossing
him to take and now it's a temple on the
rook
yeah here the question is how do I
handle blacks ADM to play c5 I can just
do this and shut it down completely
it's often a tough call if you want to
do that or not
because white will be better even if I
don't play c5 but c5 make sure that the
bishop looks silly for a long time
the only better thing here would be if I
could get the Knight to d6
it would be really nice
yeah maybe maybe I should have thought
about this a little bit longer
the before move I mean
like it helped him a little bit
you
and this is strange because I wanted to
play this move anyway
oh he basically gifted me a tempo now
the issue is that she has to weaken
himself somewhat or play Knight evade
he weakens himself and not just somewhat
but a lot
age six yeah maybe 95 but anyway getting
the night over to c4 is also interesting
[Music]
you
yeah determining determining the maximum
is not so easy here because what will be
better basically no matter what so not
so clear what the best way to convert us
I'm going to
get the night to see form it is
something okay
that you can debate about
after b5 he's basically shutting his own
bishop down
and then the night can go back because
it doesn't really do anything
only two anymore after b5 is played now
the bishop is basically dead
he only has one good piece at the knight
on d5 and I would absolutely like to
trade this one
it's not so easy maybe you could even
play Bishop C to be three and take it
that would still be a fairly large
advantage
[ __ ] 2 B 3 is also
interesting
okay
you
this is not a position where you need to
rush anything
the whites controller where the position
is pretty very pretty good and I don't
have to
be hasty in any form
so this one
no I'm threatening bishop takes a five
the aid is currently unprotected
and he has to cover six somehow I was
thinking maybe Bishop to c8 and I can
answer that can still take okay
okay and now what to do now
not not so easy
maybe this one bishop age five
three
it can be an idea to just take the d5
night
that's is only good piece and then play
with the much better Bishop on d6
compared to the bishop on b7
particularly if we get to the black king
the unopposed Bishop on d6 can be quite
strong if it comes to e5 in particular
but it's it's tough I mean here white is
better with basically anything and this
makes it sometimes more difficult than a
position where you have to find the best
move and there is just one move that you
need to identify
so I'm not sure what he's doing them
rugae 3 maybe to prevent Bishop f3
No
you
he's doing a reasonable job
pending this pretty awful position
you
yeah I'd like to
get rid of his only active piece down
not sure if this is best
you
yeah maybe
get this over to you one
rook age who I can move the Queen
you
I'm not really all that happy about
oh this turned out
I really should have a an absolutely
overwhelming advantage but it's not
totally clear-cut really
I mean it means something that he's got
the dead bishop and so on but he's not
checkmated quickly or anything and this
is something that I would have expected
to happen by now but it did not
absolutely did not now h3g force my idea
opening it up
definitely not easy for black to play
this pollution so now maybe rugae three
agree then he can actually take
whatever I have I take now
so I've got to check
this one probably the trade would be
very nice
yeah I thought that this should win
I got got this
the only issue is that da porn is so so
fast really is fast
should probably get my own porn
going
this one are threatening Queenie six
with made to come
yeah at the time was was very relevant
yep I didn't quite play it as I felt I
should should play it because the
position was so overwhelming that you
would think that it should have been
over a long long time ago
akia it's one plus two
and 11.2 I mean yeah yeah I could have
taken on f5 that is silly that I didn't
do that
yeah and then there must have been some
clear improvements
always keeping something but it's not
it's not that much
oh that's +5 razy
yeah I mean okay he's playing a bishop
down that's it's true
yeah so probably I played it better than
I thought the engine didn't really find
anything particularly wrong with what I
did
okay now playing G Flores one two or
three four
you
or the pelts nor lead on
you
this is a somewhat underrated opening I
think for black
it is not quite clearly the most
aggressive possible opening but black
gets a fairly solid position without any
great theoretical workload attached it's
not unimportant and
yeah it's kind of it's kind of
reasonable to play like that in
particular in blitz chess it's quite
important that you can
play some some quicker moves
one just go into a centralized
6.now for black
Jib age who was played to avoid stepping
into a tempo
be six for example
yeah what about d5v endless pollution
No
you
looks reasonable
and it leads to a very
radical pawn structure transformation
yeah that that easily it looks like a
Sicilian some kind of let's say slow
night off with Bishop e2 for example
Mei Deus 92 to c4
and in some cases I can also just take
it with a good position
but that would only be happening if
he's forced to take with the pawn at the
end and with Roxy 80 vended the scenario
now interesting
you
hmm interesting you can go Knights you
form
you
hmm I was bit unsure here
you
very likely just going to take on b5
Knight b6 looks annoying so I think he
will take on b5
[Music]
we are not so easy
twisting
expect that it didn't expect that to
happen
petechia night has to take
you
and want to give him see - I have some
very useful pressure on the apron
kf5
now and then take on b7 what's going on
you know also keep the bishop first on
their diagonal
yeah why not
why not
you
Oh
they don't really see anything great
from like I already could have taken on
ef5 maybe but it wasn't entirely clear
to me and he has a hard time to cover
and this side on the board the side of
the board anyway
did he do Bishop g5
No
one to trade
on 96 he had still rook takes it to
I'd like to just play something like
rookie - and then ask him about the pawn
again
and the six will also hang at some point
he cannot ignore this forever
aren't they I think it's just threatened
because 96 Roop c2 Knight f5 is just
material for white and I don't see the
compensation right now here Bishop to b6
seems good
you
and now Bishop takes a five
this is intention yeah I wanted to point
this out
yeah rather sooner than later or the
pawns are dropping
robbing like flies
Oh interesting
okay
you
of course it still continues
but whites advantage is pretty
overwhelming
you
always stuck to the
b7 porn and ultimately
should break through
you
I can also check him
and even be easier
you
there are many ways that when I just I
just tried to figure out what the
cleanest way is
you
there was no way for him to save this
and game ever she's too bad okay now um
let's go for a new opponent
Don new to the mark
all right
now I no need to promote just should not
operate in bullet mode
got enough time
yeah there are many good lines
d5 is some in the nihms oh Rico and
repertoire rookie 8 is the one that I
had in my print book
you
now white is trying to grab
more space and now all of a sudden to be
transformed into a modern benoni the
upside for widest that therefore black
is I'm sorry that white has night only -
which is just a wrong square or this for
this piece
and this is also the reason why I think
Blake is fine
this kind of structure for white was
recommended by Shonda off in his playing
d4 book which I always found really odd
because I mean if this is bad for black
then the Benoni must be entirely
unplayable they don't think it is that
bad an opening
probably pretty risky but
yeah this will definitely be very sharp
but it's not so easy for him to play e5
that's often possible with the pawn
sacrifice for example
well it isn't it or not obvious how he
should do this now B form
what
and pushing this even more
let's activate
Knight f6 this one I mean the h5 9
not leading to all that much so let's
read in 94 first
No
complicated
maybe why it is better here
but at least it's not a clear-cut fair
that this is the case still very murky
now interesting question is if f5 is
something that I should do
I just keep it like that if he now plays
93 a half night C form
maybe this is actually doing much
it's not doing much that's absolutely
true
interesting
you
v3
b3 was probably not the greatest
decision inside
tt do look II wanna okay
now I think him
he wants to prepare you five in the non
run
like Bishop back to g1 and then going
five
like that
hmm
you
yeah in some benoni positions black
manager
to trade off the d7 bishop
yeah this is so I wasn't I just wasn't
sure if it helps you know I'm going to
take this one
he md5 is hanging but it's probably not
most advisable
take
okay so the night is detect
if I take F for rookie eight takes on g3
he has to move the king away okay come
on this is a bit of a gamble gamble is
wrong I mean it's probably objectively
bad but I did not want you
sit in a passive position so take this
takes Queen takes Bishop d6 queen be a
check is an important line so it has to
move them the king
and from here maybe I can do something
let's say I take here
to know
you
and Jim
you
you can you can activate the Queen so
easily this is the thing that we need
three for example
YUM
you
Queeny once my gym
eleven seconds
you
age three is hanging
you
they won't take us a bit of a ridiculous
pre move in some way
you
eleven seconds
neither form is probably
[Music]
thing
fortunately I cannot
not just take d6 because if seven was
attacked
you
I'm not completely obvious how is
winning
weenie for maybe
you'll probably go f5 then
you
and the other night is coming I shoot
I only have ten seconds
ah who plays 93 nobody
and that was I don't know did I get
something there somewhere I felt like
once I got age 3 this wasn't so clear no
this is completely winning for me
that doesn't really surprise me we
should be six I just should keep it
and then just play em and this is
obviously super difficult in seconds
and probably here he's got it under
control were right he's got it under
control
not much to do these seven was even
stronger okay now let's go back and
request in game
you
[Music]
coned
okay
I rather play people with this
- ratings
you
no not the king please
you
you
yeah this is a very typical position out
of them
Rosso limo
my idea is to play form fool
Oh blonde kingside saw g5 h 5g four and
so on
here we go
I don't cancel yet because it might be
that it's not actually necessary anymore
now I need the Queen as well so Queen
should come to age six or something like
that
let's go Queen d6
at 46 or h6
Wow
that is extremely slow
you
okay how do we do this
interesting
this is
the super straightforward way to do it
and then second h4 let's do this
you
in Queen age for the threats will come
up really quickly
very difficult for white
just takes on h4
a g3 is something like that looks
already pretty devastating
now the question is if I need to react
to this or not
I'm going to react to it
I'm not really 100% sure that this wins
for black it's just that the whole arm
this defense should be extremely
difficult to conduct or human player now
this is hanging but I think I'm not
agree care about this
now there's also f3
or Queen age three Queens to mate
they also have Nagi
you
think you could shade
95 g3 it's that is all them
maybe King age one is still
kind of defense
I have g3 though g3 takes takes that
power
this is also threatening 95
you imagine 95 friends Knight f3 and
this is pretty much impossible to defend
so g3
g3 pawn takes pawn takes and now I
thought probably rook g1 needs to be
played
it's made such nonsense that's made when
age - of course
so what what does he do then g2 is also
the thread just had a oh interesting
didn't see this one
you should G for
and win
you
now this one right
should have three years extremely deadly
you
yeah I won't really show how correct
that was but it was friggin dangerous it
was really dangerous
I think yeah after f5 white should
absolutely take I'm fairly sure about
that
I mean before it might not be unplayable
the computer actually still likes it at
first instance but this is stockfish ed
no depth so I'm not sure about it
so f/4 goes back takes takes the night
h6
oh this this must be very dangerous
and now the engine starts to like my
position g4 immediately was also
possible
for h4 yeah no I don't know this is
certainly something where you can play
without these brutal sacrifices
it's just Bishop e6 or something because
strategically even blacks position is
completely dominating he has this White
has this enormous space disadvantage and
that would probably cost him the game
anyway my yeah this caveman approach is
not sure really yeah it seems to win I
wasn't sure I did you never know the
engine might find some some miraculous
defense but doesn't seem to be the case
yeah I could have taken immediately on
h4 and probably that wins
got a message that I have no
what it means it's in some foreign
language
so and so this is supposed to be good
for white
King edge one g3
so where is the safe hook a tool
and now rook takes f7 is the thing that
I did not
that I did not seem okay I probably have
to take it and then I have three
okay
- yeah I was kind of throwing the
kitchen sink not really
caring that much if it is scientifically
correct
kay let's go for the e4 game against dad
I'm daddy me I don't know it should lead
to somewhat simpler positions and game
before
you
um did I screw the more water up
actually
I did screw the move all up
eggs should be able to play d5 but he
can take it right because of the chicky
on edge too
somewhat irritated
wrong here if I go c4 takes d5
now I have to play c4 here right yeah
I'm a I had made the plate the wrong
move order okay it's so nothing special
yeah it's just a fairly normal position
shouldn't be worth
you
is of course a benefit of the exchange
variation that even if you screw the
move order up and it will happen
even then you quite often still retain a
fairly reasonable position
difficult to be really in terrible shape
against ER with the exchange French
now is he threatening to take I don't
think so
on age three I mean
you
my dis to just go Knight g3 maybe and
transfer to the King side
came so see really trying to take on h3
would be and so let's me as at least
grab the bishop Pam
now
you
form
okay
yeah can certainly do that
I would just I would
[Music]
expect the disposition is about equal
you
on g3 the bishop is not badly placed
I get this to g3 the other one to C form
I'm getting active again with my bishops
you
yeah 27 looks kind of
forced now 95 is that move form
is that silly 95 pawn takes rook reform
quantex deform it's probably some
compensation
it also play 92 here's a bit it's a bit
uncommon looking but it's not too bad I
think was the checking e4 and if he goes
back I'll go take a aide and play Knight
b3 rooting for night c5
I could take with the Queen it's maybe
not such a bad decision
No
yeah now night c5 is annoying p6
blunders a6
you
yeah but should be five now is a pretty
awful threat okay put this on a good
diagonal
and now the night should be
getting to some good squeeze on v3 it
was only to threaten 95 and provoke
provoke him weakened the position
now the night were come to see four I
guess I didn't spot this one that this
is actually like a double attack G for
ng3
pretty annoying
so this one
crew 97 is not
so I think I should gain
the time to play Bishop age - maybe
Queen - f7 is a move threatening Bishop
age five
no df5 is hanging so that is not a
threat
you
okay yeah I would like to
keep the passion
and now 94 is a good move next
looking at d6
Bob Bishop b3 Bishop d3 ever that could
be night III or night h6 actually pretty
we stupid shouldn't do that now you just
you just let the clock run out so um
let's go for a rematch in this game
probably one more game after that and
then
going to
for with this session
what's so running out of team
you
yeah I'm just playing the normal Museum
in this line off the recursion Bishop d3
is a little bit
a little bit uncommon because
you can play rook c1 and sometimes get
to trade in
in one move
I get to take in one move I mean on C
form
you
yeah extremely standard
get from all kinds of Queen's Gambit
declines I'm going to play b6 Bishop e7
books the eighth that's the plan
it's not much that white can do about
the second plane between a forward I can
switch gears play Bishop d7
in general our two minor pieces have
been traded um black should not
experience that many difficulties
attending night takes deform only takes
it interesting
you
surprising the team decided to give up
his bishop and play with the night
now got many options I can preserve the
bishop and I think I'm going to do that
Y can take actually
[Music]
it's going to keep the bishop
my basic idea is to move the Queen then
play f6 and then return to c6 that's
what I what I want to do
you
mmm Jim I can just take this
it's really no particular reason not to
do it
one I just go back I go b5 I'm sorry and
yeah I can play Bishop c2
no can take deform
I don't see any intermediate moves that
you can try
you know the bishop is actually covered
now he still has rooks e1 next
but if I go here
still as Roxy one that was stupid
you
and he's on c8 I was just born up for
nothing and now I'm into this nonsense
awful
pretty done awful
you
trying to play Bishop d3 next
you
now Bishop d3 is possible and say Knight
goes back BAM Bishop III it's it's a
month
you can play Quincy a quintic ca10 but
okay then the game continuous so I
haven't blundered see to fully I mean I
didn't it didn't quite register to me
whatever what I did here what was wrong
that same but so okay Queenie aid
wouldn't take it as si8 was hanging but
now CA discovered and tonight is
attacked twice so if the night goes back
I can just move the bishop out whatever
you for most like him
you
you
okay I just have one check doesn't
really help much
but II five
yeah
and blundering queens no there's no
Quincy for okay
you
just wanted to play more active Liam
[Music]
ticking doesn't work
don't have anything good really
you
you
- slow
Knight f5 a blonde at night f5 that was
a bad game and yeah me I kind of know
what it is if you have such a long day
ok did today a can of plain nonsense 9f5
that was already the second game against
him right now let's go for one more new
opponent and then call it a day under a
1966 maybe I can win
out of theory something like that it
would probably help
pretty odd variation that Andre is
playing him
looks like a brilliant French defense
III Wow
you
yeah I gained lots of space on that side
of the board and
about his intentions there it really
looks pretty weird
d4 is strong
yeah maybe default stuff to say what's
best gym
you
93
looks costly somehow
it looks very strange
very very strange
I'm not sure that I'm winning material
though
this one isn't III hanging
it is hanging
now you can actually think about taking
on c1 because the night on e3 is so
devastatingly strong yeah I think I'm
doing this taking the exchange is of
course fine but
just have a look at denied only three is
just fantastic fantastic peas
Bishop f5 maybe yeah
no um f6 I guess
don't win material yet is there not not
seeing it Oh
this is a move that I should have seen
beforehand
didn't do that
yeah at the end of the day you should
just take take the materia take the
exchange and go home I wanted to do
something better and now I'm of course
in good shape but you kind of ask
yourself how you're winning this game
and I would have just taken the exchange
it probably would have been over by now
really possible
I don't want to take
houki to adjust continuous adjust the
position
yeah if I've then I guess
it's not super clear but
six is called 96
was a check my king is on c8 ouch I can
be really happy that he didn't see that
you see he saw this one
that could have been even worse
you
I'm overlooking stuff
I mean I do I mean just like concretely
here
did I overlook something I don't quite
see it
yeah there is no
should be for some
to have to avoid
you
eighty-four maybe coming I don't know
this said don't mind at all King bieed
is useful and I have now Bishop takes
two 3s even stronger
you
now there is nothing right just a chick
okay
you
something better than the chick
I don't know that it's enough
you
yeah tricky business but I didn't really
meet
the great opening position account that
much it should have been much cleaner
and I think I just blundered at some
point we just really check the position
here is just overwhelmingly good and
here I should probably just take the
material I could take here take this and
and it's gone but I was just too too
into the aesthetic about at the great
night I mean okay it is very good but
it's not as good as it should have been
and now things are really murky and of
course reliably i blundered if i was
just just stupid to know no end yeah
just ninety six now wins he wins both
pieces it's all check and in this false
so if i was
yeah after that things are okay again
not as winning as ever before which I
don't need
doesn't work right yeah I don't don't
really need to very all that much
anymore so that was a pretty pretty
lucky win okay guys I hope you enjoyed
it I'll be back tomorrow I guess and
yeah I think let's see ya probably
tomorrow with another blitz session but
I have something else planned so keep it
tuned bye bye